are you looking forward to the hitman  beta this weekend hopefully you have a  good internet provider because you'll  need to be connected at all times but  here's the good news that won't be the  case when the full game launches in  March Square Enix confirmed to  videogamer that a constant internet  connection is not required for the full  release once you download an episode  you're free to play offline of course  there will be certain elements of the  game you'll need to be online in order  to access agent 47 can't operate when  he's totally off the grid the hitman  beta hits ps4 this Friday February 12th  then PC on the 19th the full game will  arrive on ps4 Xbox one and PC on March  11 if Square Enix reveals any more about  agent 47s latest outing you'll hear  about it from GameSpot